What's going on? My name is Alan Drau
and I have studied over 101 viral
headlines written by some of the
greatest copywriters to ever live. I
studied them. I broke them down and I
dissected seven secret psychological
triggers that will help you attract more
attention, get more readers, and get
more buyers on your email list, your
info products, and anything else you
want to do just by injecting these into
your headlines. And I'm going to break
down everything in this video. I'm going
to give away all the sauce and the
secrets. And if you watch until the end,
you may just not need to watch any other
video on writing headlines ever again.
Again, my name is Alan Dre. I've made
over $2 million writing copy for myself
and my own business. I'm a number one
bestselling author of the book
Meaningful Marketing, and I have over
5,000 copywriters who study my emails
every single day. This is what I do all
day long. You ready to jump in?
>> All right. So check this out. Before we
actually dive into the seven
psychological triggers, you have to
understand the people you are writing
for. Because writing a headline and
grabbing attention is more about the
person you are trying to reach than the
headline you are trying to write. Okay?
And that boils down to these five things
that you have to understand before you
ever take your pen to the paper. Okay?
These five things and I boiled it down
very simply for you. Okay? starts with
their desires, dreams, pains, fears, and
obstacles. All right, let's break each
one of them down very quick. And in a
second, I'm going to give you a secret
tool to help learn all this thing about
your audience without having to do like
literally any work. All right, so watch
this. Desires. What does your audience
want today? Let's talk about like
freelance copywriters. I talked to a
bunch of freelance copywriters and I can
tell you right now, the thing that they
want today always is clients. I want
clients. Okay, if I write any headline
that's like get clients today, it would
rip because I know that's their biggest
desire. They want clients. But let's
unpack that a little bit. What does that
look like? If I talk about their pains,
what is hurting them right now? Well,
what's hurting them is probably not
having money, right? Freelance
copyriters, they want to make sure, man,
I I need more money. I need to pay my
bills. I need to pay uh for my vacation
with my family. I got to pay for things.
I got to pay for groceries and all this
kind of stuff. What's hurting me is I
don't have enough money. I need that.
That's hurting them right now. Which
then takes us to the next thing. Well,
what do they want in the future? It
can't just be what do they want today.
What do they want in the future? And
what they want in the future is freedom
and autonomy and financial freedom.
Okay? They want they want the ability to
have their time back and travel the
world and and be able to decide whether
they want this project or that project
or wake up and not have to worry about
the pressure and the weight of cash,
right? So, that's what they want in the
future. And now, now your wheels are
turning. You're like, "Okay, my
goodness, now I'm starting to know these
guys." Well, what are they scared of?
Well, they're scared of letting their
family down. They're scared of not being
able to feed their kids. They're scared
of not being able to pay for their house
and they're going to have to move places
and not make it rent and all that.
They're terrified of that. You have to
think through that in headline writing.
Well, what's getting in their way? Well,
what's getting in their way is maybe
they don't have the skill set to write
persuasive copy. Maybe they don't have
the skill set to uh network with people
or cold outreach or get clients or maybe
they just don't know what the next step
is. So, you have to understand these
things. Now, one of my favorite ways to
grab this sort of information, at least
the skeleton of this information, is
using a secret market research AI prompt
set that me and my friend Ben Fidman
built together. In fact, I made an
entire video on how to use it. Here's a
card like somewhere up here. You can
click that and it includes the prompts,
but I'll put the link in the description
below for the prompts themselves. You
just put your email in and it'll send
you the prompt document, all five steps,
and you can turn it and use it with
chatbt or Gemini or whatever, and it
does all the market research for you
exactly in this structure. So that way
you know significantly more about your
target audience before you ever write a
single headline. All right, now that
this makes sense, let's move over to the
seven psychological secret triggers that
is going to make your headlines punch
harder than ever before. All right,
starting with psychological secret
number one, and that is curiosity. Gary
Halper, one of the highest paid
copywriters to ever live and walk this
planet, said that curiosity is the
number one drug that will sell anyone to
anything. Okay? And curiosity is a drug.
It's a dopamine drug that hits your
brain. This is scientific that it hit
your but the minute it hits your brain
that when you get somebody curious about
something that they truly care about,
they cannot physically move or do the
next thing until they figure out what
that thing is. So curiosity is your
number one secret. And I'm going to show
you how it plays out right here. So
we're talking about freelance
copywriters, okay? Well, if I were to
write a headline that said something
like the copywriting secrets you were
never told, think about the curiosity in
that. Okay? What you do in this is you
actually open a story loop. Okay? You
open a loop. You open a question mark in
their head and you create this gap
between where they are today and what
they want to know. Okay? So, here's the
person. Here's the person that you're
reading to and they're here on this
mountain. And what I just did was I
created this huge gap where I'm over
here and I say, "Hey, I know something
that you don't know." And now to get
over to me, they have to read my sales
page. They have to read my sales letter.
They have to read my tweet. They have to
read something like this to get them
over to where I am. That is how they
cross the gap between their curiosity
because this gap is just their
curiosity. Okay? And so you may read a
headline like this because it matches
with their pains and their desires. They
may be someone who doesn't have the
right copywriting skill set yet. They're
like, "Maybe that's why I'm not getting
clients. Maybe that's why I'm not making
enough money. Maybe that's why the copy
that I write isn't selling enough
because there are some secrets that I
was never told. These copywriting
secrets that I was never told." And that
curiosity eats away at them. And so you
have to think about what does your
target audience care about? remember
their dreams, their obstacles, their
pains and desires. And how can you open
up a loop that creates curiosity for
them to no matter what they have to stop
what they're doing to click now and
solve that curiosity gap? What is the
question already in their head? Let me
give you another example. Okay, here's a
headline that I genuinely personally
wrote on Twitter and it went mega viral.
I'm talking hundreds of thousands of
impressions, thousands of likes and
comments and things like that. So, this
is what I wrote. I wrote, "I fired a
$6,000 a month client." Here's what
happened. Okay, I knew this would rip
for multiple reasons. One, it's a
storybased headline, which story based
headlines open up the loops. A lot of
curiosity. Well, what happens? Everybody
wants to know what happens in a good
story. So, it taps into curiosity
tremendously. The next thing is it taps
into the pains, dreams, hopes, and
desires of freelance copywriters. They
want $6,000 a month clients. And so when
I say that I fired one, it goes against
the grain of their desires and their
dreams. And so when you do something
that contrasts, which we'll talk more
about that later, what they actually do
desire and their dreams, and I address
that in a headline, the curiosity goes
through the roof. Well, what happened?
What is it? Why would they do that?
Because their internal desires and
dreams want something. I did the
opposite. So, the curiosity explodes.
So, that's your first one. Those are a
couple examples of how to use curiosity.
Let's go to secret number two. All
right. Secret number two in writing
banger headlines is pain. Directly
addressing one of the key emotions that
we talked about a little bit earlier is
writing a headline that attacks I'm
sorry, agitates their pain. Okay. So I
may write a headline like this. Okay.
Why 99% of new copywriters fail? That is
a pain that they want to move away from.
Something they want to deeply run away.
I don't want to fail. I want clients. I
want to make money. I want to provide
for my family. They don't want to fail.
That would be so painful. That would
hurt them so much that they have to
click this. Not only does it inject the
first thing, curiosity, which I'll talk
about secret stacking later, this
actually directly addresses one of their
pains and it agitates it with saying
here's why it happens and they can't not
click this because it directly talks to
them. Let me give you another example.
Do you make these mistakes in client
outreach? Again, this is agitating the
pain. actually increases the urgency of
somebody willing to fix their pain
because when I start calling out
something like something that they're
doing very often, right? Client outreach
is an activity that copywriters,
freelance copywriters are specifically
trying to figure out so they can solve
their pain, solve their frustration,
achieve their dreams, achieve their
desires. So when I call out that pain
and I say, "Are you making these
mistakes?" You may see that and see be
like, "Oh my gosh, I'm not getting the
results." So, yes, I must be making some
sort of mistakes. Again, I'm attacking
the pain that they're feeling because if
the right person isn't getting the
results, that's that's a frustration.
They're like, "Ah, I wish I was getting
more clients. I wish people were
responding to my outreach." And when I
say, "Hey, are you making these
mistakes? I'm attacking agitating the
thing that they want to do better." All
right, make sense. Well, we're cooking.
We're cooking. All right. By the way, if
this is helpful to you, I have written
all of these headlines and more, the 101
headlines that I have studied. I put
them in a dock. I've templatized them
and I've told you how to use them. You
can get that doc for free just by
clicking the link in the description
below. Put your email in and I'll send
it directly to you so that way you can
use them and swipe all these great
headlines for yourself to be able to
rewrite them and use them for yourself.
So, check that out if that's helpful.
Let's go ahead and move on to secret
number three. Secret number three to
writing banger headlines is promise.
Okay, a promise taps into both the
dreams and the desires both future and
now of your current target audience and
it makes them feel like you're giving
them hope for the future. So that's what
a good promise does. A good promise
again is like it's creating this gap.
It's creating this gap, but not to
overcome and understand their curiosity,
but to give them a path, a stepping
stone path to help them move from where
they are today to where they want to be
in the future. Okay, they're saying,
"Yay!" Okay, they've reached their goal.
Your headline helps them reach their
goal. It's like, "Here's how to do
that." All right, so here's a headline
that I see all the time, and it works
because it taps into this innate emotion
desire, right? It works. how to make
$10,000 a month with copyrightiting.
That is a desire and it is a dream. They
want to make long-term 10 grand a month
so they can make 100 grand, 120 grand a
year supporting their family, taking
care of their kids, all this stuff. And
it is a pain. It's a it's a it's a big
promise for their what they want today.
I need some clients, right? So, this
obviously is going to get me clients.
And so what you're doing is you're
tapping into something they already
want, a promise that they already
desire, and you're telling them how to
get it. You're not injecting something
new to them. You're not like, I can help
you do this random thing. I can help you
blah blah blah. It's not your desire.
It's their desire and you're promising
them how to achieve their desire. Let me
show you one more example. Okay, so
here's another take on that headline. If
you've got 20 minutes, I guarantee I
could teach you copywriting. This is one
of Gary Benson's headlines where he
says, uh, unbelievably short amount of
time for unbelievably big promise. Okay,
I could teach you copywriting in this
video in 20 minutes. That's a big
promise that taps into the desire of
someone. Someone wants to know, well, I
want to know copywriting. Well, what's
the what's the big dream? Well, because
I want to get clients and make my own
business and things like that. So this
is a big promise for the current desire.
The current desire is I want to know
copyrightiting. When you write something
like this unbelievably short amount of
time for unbelievably big promise and
keeping it semi-realistic. This is a
great way to tap into the promise that
you're going to inject in your copy so
that someone is more persuasive to click
this headline, read the article, buy
from you, whatever it is. And again, all
these headline templates and things like
that are in a link in the description
below. So you can see all kinds of
variables on how to write this. But that
is secret number three, promise. Let's
go to secret number four. Secret number
four is specificity. The more specific
you can make your headlines, the more
believable that your headline actually
is. Because when you make vague, broad
statements, people don't tend to attach
to that and it doesn't feel real. It
feels like this generic noise statement,
but when you specify it, it feels, well,
this is real. This might be an actual
story. this might be someone telling me
the truth because most people believe
that ads and marketers are all liars.
They believe everything is a scam, that
everybody's just trying to sell them
something and nobody's actually trying
to help them. So, when you increase your
specificity, you increase the
believability, which increases the
likelihood that someone will click your
ad or read your article or anything like
that to actually dive in. So, you have
to inject this inside of your headlines.
Here's an example. Could or can you
write killer copy? Neither could I 3
months ago. That 3 months ago is a very
specific time frame that actually makes
it feel like, wo, this this probably
really happened, right? If I say, can
you write killer copy? Neither could I a
long time ago. That okay, fantastic.
Neither could I. Doesn't matter, right?
But the fact that we said 3 months ago,
somebody will read that and be like,
"Oh, well, what did what did the guy do
that allowed him to write killer copy?"
Which again is promise. That's a pro.
Could you write killer copy? It's also a
pain. I can't write killer copy. It also
injects curiosity. We're stacking these
things. Can you write killer copy? Oh,
neither could I 3 months ago. Well, what
did he do now? What did he do that he
could write? See, do you see how we're
stacking the secret elements to make
these things more persuasive. So, you
want to be really specific. Let me give
you another example of how to be really
specific. how I write 1,786
words every morning by 8:00 a.m. Do you
see the two levels of specificity there?
1,786
words. I didn't say a lot of words. I
didn't say thousands of words. I didn't
even use like one of those generic like
two thou like I didn't say like 2,000
words cuz that feels fake when you just
add a bunch of zeros. But when you're
super specific and you say 1786, people
are like, "Oh, that's a specific number.
That feels real. that feels like
something that would actually happen.
And then you say, "Every morning by 8:00
a.m." I could have said by 8:17 a.m.,
but I already did the hyperspecific
thing there. So, I wanted to make this
really simple, which we'll talk about in
a little bit. But by 8:00 a.m., now
we've doubled the specificity. How I
write this many words, very specific
number by a very specific time. And so
now you read something like this and you
say, "This is obviously true. If I click
this, this is going to be a real story
about how this guy actually does it that
I can learn." which taps into the
curiosity, pains, and desires. All
right, so that's secret number four.
Let's go to secret number five. All
right, secret number five is simplicity.
All right, there's a couple copywriters
that did this really, really well. Gary
Beno, which he wrote this headline, and
Joe Sugarman. Joe Sugarman wrote a
different headline uh that said vision
breakthrough, which we'll break that
down a little bit, but lies, lies, lies,
is a headline from Gary Benga. The
reason this works so well is because
when you read a statement like that, you
can't not just read the next line, which
is a Joe Sugarman principle that the
headline and the lead and everything
like that should be like a slippery
slide for your target audience that once
they read one thing, they're inclined to
continue reading the next. And a simple
short headline does that perfectly
because you read lies, lies, lies will
inject enough curiosity, right? The
number one secret is curiosity that
anybody would be willing to read the
second line after lies, lies, lies.
You'd read that and you'd be like,
"Well, what's a lie?" And it it was so
easy to read the first one, it took no
bandwidth in your head. So naturally,
you read the second line. So another way
that uh Joe Sherman did this is he did
vision
breakthrough. Okay, vision breakthrough
was a huge headline that sold like
bananas for him for his blue blocker
glasses. It was like some $49 blue
blocker head uh glasses that he sold.
Now, all he started with was that he
didn't say how to block this and how to
benefit this and none of that. He just
said vision breakthrough, which caught a
ton of attention because it's such a
simple headline. You read that and
you're like, oh, what's the next line
and then what's the next line? So, it's
a great way to get people down a very
slippery slide. Now, again, the best
pairing with simplicity has to be
curiosity, right? Vision breakthrough,
you want to know what the breakthrough
is. So, anytime you do something very
simple, it has to be curiositydriven.
You can't just do something like when
can't do it cuz that doesn't make any
sense. When what? I don't understand.
Like, that might work, but you have to
do something way more curiosity driven.
lies is who's lying? Vision
breakthrough. What breakthrough? So,
lean into that for your simplicity. All
right, very simple lesson. Let's go to
secret number six. Secret number six to
writing banger headlines is proof. Proof
increases the believability that you are
not just shilling bull crap down
people's throats and that you have the
authority to actually speak and teach on
what you are writing about. Okay, so let
me break down a headline that has a good
bit of proof. And I'm going to show you
the other secrets injected in here. This
headline says, "I wasted $5,000
on copywriting courses. This one thing
worked." Okay, so here's a couple
elements that work really, really well.
That I wasted $5,000. That is a proof
element that I spent $5 grand on
copywriting courses. So that gives me
the proof to say this one thing worked.
meaning I went through all this and I
spent this much money. So, this one
thing has a lot more oomph to it because
of the proof that I injected earlier
into the headline. Now, if we wanted to
really juice this up, we might want to
say like, I wasted $5,168.
So, we can inject the specificity there.
And then the other thing, the
simplicity. This one thing works. So,
now it's very simple to understand what
you're doing. But it starts with the
proof. I did something that earns me
equity to talk about this thing right
here. Let me show you one more example.
All right, another example of proof in
this headline is Alex Coros's funnel
framework explained. Now, look at how I
did proof here. I actually hijacked
someone else's authority. So, Alex
Hermoszi, right? Big guru figure. A lot
of people trust him. A lot of people
follow him, study his work. Well, I'm
using his name as proof for content that
I write. This is called authority
hijacking. And you could absolutely use
this as proof, right? And I'm using that
to explain his funnel framework, which
is a desire amongst freelance copyriters
because they want to understand his
funnels better for their clients. And I
do explain something very simple. I'm
going to explain his funnel framework.
So, there's proof, there's simplicity,
there's desire pain, right? all of that
in here. And of course, naturally
drenched in everything is curiosity. The
number one secret. You have to know what
this is, but I'm doing it with a way
that actually starts with injecting
proof upfront. So that way it gives me
the authority to say the rest of what I
want to say after. All right. So that is
secret number six. Let's go to the last
and final deadly secret that is going to
help you write banger headlines. That is
number seven. Secret number seven is
time frame. Whenever you can inject a
specific time frame into some sort of
promise or pain or desire or anything
like that that you are writing for
someone, it makes it so much more
desirable. People want to know that they
can get something fast or in a specific
time. And what it does is it actually
creates a road map for your promise. All
right? So if I make a promise like this,
make your first dollar online in one
hour. That phrase right there, in 1
hour, makes the headline so much more
desirable. Now, it may just say, make
your first dollar online. Okay, that's a
that's a promise. Interesting. But when
you add something like in 1 hour, in 7
days, in 30 days, and you have to
balance this, right? If you were to say
make your first dollar online in 60
seconds, well, that's a scam. If you say
make your first dollar online in 7 days,
that's interesting. If you say make make
your first dollar online in one hour,
that's like whoa, that's very
interesting. Can I actually do that? So
now it's now it's I'm at the peak of
that. But if I say make your first
dollar online in 12 months, it's not
interesting at all because I'm like I
don't want to wait 12 months. You can
also do this with lose 10 lb, lose 10
lbs in 5 hours, lose 10 lbs in 5 days,
lose 10 lbs in 5 years. Do you see the
levels that we do? So, you take some
sort of promise or desire that they
want, make it really simple and
specific, and then add a time frame to
it. Bada bing, bada boom, you have
yourself a significantly more
interesting headline. Now that you know
the seven secrets, let's recap really
quick. Your seven secrets are one,
curiosity. This is by far the most
important one. Two, pain. Number three,
promise. Number four, specificity. Five,
simplicity. Six, proof. And seven,
timeline. And these become really
powerful when you could start stacking
them. Just how I was showing you with
headlines earlier. We had a headline
that was all dripping in curiosity. It
attacked the painoint. It made a really
specific timeline promise and it was
very specific. Okay. So, when you start
doing things like these four elements
are on one headline, you start getting
some really powerful headlines. I got
tons of examples like this again in my
101 super sticky viral hooks framework.
It's down in the description below. You
can grab that. It's going to walk
through these things. It's going to give
you templates on all kinds of headlines
to write. And it's going to make you a
more persuasive copywriter to get
clicks, attention, sales, all that stuff
when you can unlock this one valuable
meta skill inside of copywriting, and
that is writing banger headlines. So, I
hope this was helpful for you. If it
was, please do me a favor. I'm asking
you, please do me a favor. Like this
video, comment down below, and subscribe
to the channel. Okay? It takes you two
seconds to hit that subscribe button,
hit a like, and it tells the YouTube
algorithm that you want more content
from me. You want me to add more value
to your life for free. El Gratis, okay?
Couldn't be easier. So, please do that
for me. Giving you a bunch of stuff. Go
ahead and grab those headline templates,
all that cool stuff. I hope this was
helpful to you. Thank you so much, and I
will catch you on the next one.